so last week we retired the rap game
little browse demolished the winner 92
to 8% and so this week we're gonna do
our name game but I thought before we
did we bring in a celebrity judge he's
actually got theme music what's up you
talented dude
[Music]
well brows got to pop this off real
quick welcome himself see you man what's
going on love the song man yeah now it's
been good I didn't know you guys were
right here I play a like hacky sack in
this park all the time yeah yeah guys
only good at the only spores you go to
this cheerleader this guy couldn't hack
you to save his life um what's going on
man you live here in LA yeah I live I
live right around here
oh wow do you know your rap submission
was gonna [ __ ] set the world on fire
dude I was just driving through a
chick-fil-a parking lot and I heard some
stuff going in I was like I can go in on
this I think I can I think I can
penetrate yeah just go have you seen
some other Simmons yeah I mean I think
my favorite one it's a little cringe my
favorite one was the guy that's like
what do you say like just couple words
he's like things that things like yeah
they got bad yeah yeah
yeah they got bad man that heard the
urban lady the lady that did that
remember by the window lady then there's
that one dude who's I come out to
[ __ ] kill little brows this is off
the top of the dome then it was real
racial yeah yeah also white he dropped
the N bomb in he was white yeah excusing
and then some people from death threats
do you wouldn't even send this to you
man right yeah I got a couple we got so
what are you doing now he's the guest
job looks like this like America got
Stalin it what's up dog
what you got Nick before we before we
get to the submissions we have one more
surprise for little brows wing that in
because we wanted to honor him since we
returned new car plus justice filthy
broke way nicer than the strap that I
got from firing the kid the first time
the firt the first one come on is my
first belt yeah the second one the
second one is to my little brows on
there's a bra very thick that's really
tight they meant don't his dope yeah
take that strap we gotta get a picture
with him with that I think Papio tune
did that uh cartoon yes he did honest
dope in that furrier on it get that
first side nothing the one you got me
with sharp on the back yeah had more of
like astroturf feel to it very dangerous
man Dan that's awesome bro oh yeah you
deserve it man dude I walk out to it all
my all my shows I mean once everything
opens up I'm trying to turn up with you
guys open it up
yeah do a live King this thing he opens
it up yeah I'll be really cool man store
there'd be a lot of fun do you do a lot
of other music stuff what type of stuff
do you do so I've really just got into
putting music out like over the past six
months like I've been making music I was
younger and my older brother would
always rap and stuff so I would like got
into it and I just kept getting a little
better and better but um yeah I think I
was just always too scared to like take
it serious and put stuff out it's top
white rapper right yeah and I really
don't even like dude honestly like I'm
more into just making like actual songs
but I'd do that for like the shock value
so kind of had to slide in here with the
bars but then I'm trying to transition
into like actual musics follow up when I
thought it was funny at the end where
you guys just have like the guys dance
and his stuff oh we're mopping out that
was dude Eric was out there from where
oh hi oh yeah yeah yeah they got good
rappers in Ohio
yeah Millard rest in peace he's not from
okay that was a tough kid cudi
right that's like the first rap I ever
heard was like bone thugs-n-harmony my
brother played it for me when I was like
10 and they they do the real quick like
hit him in a minute when everything went
get him up because of him and I need
like that time quick chop flow like MGK
does so big brows your brother rap he
can rap yeah did your rat still wrapping
up no he kind of like freestyles around
a little bit yeah yeah yeah little
freaking brows with a surprise huh
that's so dope good job Nick um did you
have did you whenever you put your rap
in like were you when you when you first
like okay they got some competitors did
you think if some of those were gonna be
legit to be honest like usually when
people are like let me show you my music
it's usually not that great and yes you
know I I do that too like I don't like
to really be like hey check this out cuz
I know it's gonna be like but I just
feel pretty confident in my ability so I
was like I'm just gonna submit that
whatever happens yeah this is kind of
the perfect environment for it to it
it's like it's fun it's kind of
light-hearted you know it's a little bit
ridiculous but we expect to be that
good yeah yeah well you know the
submissions with Tier I'll be won from
[Laughter]
there was some real cat [ __ ] the last
one little guy with the damn weasel
really guy with the damn hit me on the
DM z-- trying to shoot a video I can't
do a seance I don't know what's going on
with that DME Tuesday I know my shits
weird but that shit's fire I pretend I
don't see well now he knows and you guys
didn't see the ones we didn't play on
the show I mean it's it's a different
level important it has to go through him
forgot said I would love to do a cat's
rap battle roast some time where we go
through those cuz there's plenty left
over and some of them are comically bad
yeah maybe we'd have brows back in and
do I'll just go through some of the
submissions that came in yeah that's so
funny just really just burn all rap
battle we just roast them ya know
browser because I like we'll talk about
some of them on the episode and then
I'll watch the episode back and I'm like
Jesus it's funny cuz I'm but I always be
at home just writing like a I don't know
a suicide note or something and I will
and you're a babe but you're beating
your theme right up into my head oh good
yeah I'm gonna have to find some ways to
incorporate it in a great Lodge no keep
making music man we need the old round
oh yeah yeah I'm gonna put some
inspirational stuff and shoot it over to
you you don't give up
so did you move out here to work in
entertainment or what I actually moved
out of here to get sober to be
completely honest right now just kind of
random because I went like into LA and
you know just kind of weird verse to
come to get sober yeah yeah yeah it
makes no sense but yeah I was just like
[ __ ] up what was your choice opiates
yeah yeah yeah or fun yeah yeah opiates
are big in the mid where I guessed
everywhere huh
yeah pills it was like pills and stuff
yeah oxy yeah like all that yeah yeah
but yeah there's nothing like going on
in the Midwest like when I go home it's
just like you know small town one
stoplight yeah
[Music]